we're now only a couple of days away
from Apple's scary fast October event
and it looks like we already have
confirmation that this event will be
focused on new 14 and 16-in MacBook Pros
with the M3 Pro and M3 Max chips but
wait a second what about the regular M3
chip is Apple really going to skip it
and save it for next year or is that
actually coming next week as well and if
it is which consumer Maxs are going to
show up well that's a exactly what I'm
going to answer in this video by
explaining two plausible theories
surrounding the M3 chip reveal but first
I want to get into exactly what you
should expect in terms of the new
features specs and performance of those
new high-end MacBook Pros as far as the
design we shouldn't expect any physical
changes at all on the outside now there
are some who think we might be getting a
matte black version of the MacBook Pro
but they could easily stay exactly the
same as for the features the one one
thing I can see them possibly adding is
face ID into the already existing Notch
that by itself would make it more of a
desirable upgrade for those who love
face ID on their iPhones but other than
that there really isn't much to upgrade
until they fully redesign it in a couple
of years so most of the changes are
going to be on the inside specifically
with the new Chips starting with the M3
Pro this one is quite interesting
because Mark German leaked the specs
back in May and some of it didn't really
make much sense for example it was seen
packed with 12 cores six performance and
six efficiency a total of two more than
the M2 Pro chip and oddly 18 GPU cores
which is actually one less than the 19
GPU cores on the current M2 Pro that
basically means that this leaked M3 Pro
chip was actually a bin base model chip
just like we currently have on the M2
Pro where the bin chip only has 10 CPU
cores and 16 GPU cores but if you pay to
upgrade it it goes up to 12 CPU and 19
GPU so my theory with this leaked M3 Pro
is that the full unbinned M3 Pro chip is
actually going to have 14 CPU cores with
eight performance and six efficiency
with a 20 core GPU and then another
weird Det detail was the fact that the
leaked M3 Pro chip had 36 GB of RAM
which is odd because right now the
current M2 Pro chip can come with either
16 or 32 gigs this basically proves that
the entire M3 family of chips will come
with brand new 12 GB Ram modules finally
raising the base RAM on the regular M3
from the current 8 gigs up to 12 gigs of
RAM which is huge oh and and by the way
the core layout for the regular M3 is
rumored to stay the same you got four
performance cores four efficiency as
well as the same 10 core GPU so don't
expect massive performance jumps there
now moving on to the M3 Max chip this is
where it gets very interesting first of
all the leak chip that Mark German saw
in August came with 48 GB of RAM which
is even more proof that the new RAM
chips will come in 12 GB modules with
four of them going into the 3 Max but
the most insane detail was that it
actually had a crazy 16 CPU cores a huge
jump from the current M2 Max that has 12
so for the first time the max will
actually have a much better CPU than the
pro which honestly makes so much more
sense but making it even better there
will apparently be 12 performance cores
a 50% increase from the current eight
with the same four efficiency cores as
we have right now because of this we're
expecting a massive performance jump in
terms of the CPU being almost as fast as
the M2 Ultra chip which is two M2 Maxes
put together this Chip is going to blow
minds but as far as the graphics we're
expecting a small jump up to 40 GPU
cores from the previous 38 so graphics
performance is not going to see a huge
difference so with that said what about
the regular M3 chip is that also showing
up at this event or not well there are
two different options for what can
happen at this event or basically two
separate theories so let's start with
Theory number one at this upcoming
October 30th event only the M3 Pro and
M3 Max chips will be announced focusing
on just the high-end MacBook Pros which
we pretty much know will happen at this
point thanks to a recent Box league that
seems completely legit and in that case
since we'd be getting the M3 Pro and Max
MacBook Pro Pros first I totally
recommend just buying the base 14-in
model right now instead of waiting for
the airs mainly because of the
performance differences and the lack of
ports on the air models which really
sucks compared to having a huge variety
on these MacBook Pro Models but
thankfully our sponsor basis has the
perfect solution with their super
affordable 13 in1 Hub which gives you
more ports than you'll ever need with
micro and regular SD card slots with
high 4 mgab pers second transfer speed a
headphone jack four USB ports labeled
with their speeds three of them
supporting super fast 10 GB per second
file transfer speeds including a type-c
port and an Ethernet Jack as for the
display outputs while Apple's MacBook
Air is limited to One external display
the Hub itself can support a triple
display setup you can use the USBC Port
as well as the two HDMI that support 4K
60 HZ displays the the display port that
supports 4K at 120 HZ and a VGA port and
finally it has an additional pass
through charging USBC Port that can
supply 85 wats of charging power so
you're left with the perfect hub for the
15-in MacBook Air so go ahead and order
the basis 13 in1 hub for your Macbook
today using the link in the description
and pinned comment below now getting
back to Theory number one a delayed M3
chip launch until next year would likely
mean that Apple would be us using the
second generation n3e process from tsmc
for the M3 chip before later giving it
to the a18 pro chip in the iPhone the
main reason for this is that n3e has
much better yields which better matches
the higher demand for the less expensive
consumer focused Macs like the MacBook
Air this would solve all of the chip
yield issues and it would give Apple
experience and more time to optimize the
n3e process and preparation for those
iPhone 16 Pro Models with n3e chips
however there are a couple of issues
with this Theory first of all it would
be really weird for Apple to skip the M3
chip reveal and save it for later while
revealing the M3 Pro and Max and then on
top of that Mark Gman has been hinting
at the 24-in iMac coming very soon with
the M3 chip due to all the shipping
delays that we have with current iMac
and then that brings us to Theory number
two apple is going to reveal the M3 the
M3 Pro and M3 Max all at the same time
next week which sounds a bit weird but
there are a couple of good reasons for
this as well reason number one is that
Apple's M2 series of Max were selling
terribly bad because everybody thought
that they were stop Gap products so
they're waiting for three nanometer Max
which I actually believe is true mingua
himself who is a very reputable leaker
has said that Apple could be pushing to
get their Max onto 3 nanometer M3 series
chips because of bad M2 Max sales mainly
because the performance jump just wasn't
that impressive using the same 5 nmet
node as the M1 family of chips this is
actually something I said last year when
I thought the M2 Pro and Max would be
the first 3 nanometer chips I said that
if the entire M2 Chip family ends up
being on 5 nanm again then they would
basically be D away or Dead on Arrival
because they'd be really disappointing
products and look where we are now with
worse than expected sales for all of the
M2 series Max so Theory number two could
be happening because apple is Calling it
Quits on M2 skipping straight to M3
faster than previously planned in an
attempt to save their Max sales however
if the M3 chip comes it'll likely be
limited to the M3 iMac at first
alongside a 13-in MacBook Pro and then
they'd wait until next year for the new
Macbook airs another reason this second
theory might make sense is because Apple
could potentially be moving to a new
special special chip design method in
order to improve the yields of these n3b
chips that have pretty bad yields right
now and they would also improve their
profit margins iave Dave had a theory
that if Apple released the M3 M3 Pro and
M3 Max chips at the same time next week
it might be because they're planning to
create a single M3 Max die and cut it
down into the M3 Pro and then cut it
again into the regular M3 greatly
improving yields just like apple was
doing with the Max and Pro dies ever
since the M1 family I honestly don't
know how much this makes sense but it's
definitely an interesting idea but
anyway those are the specs and
performance and leaks of the M3 series
of chips and I really hope they come
next week and if you're as excited as I
am for this event definitely subscribe
above for our upcoming in-depth
comparison videos and check out one of
those right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
video